we crossed a hundred thousand subs we're
at a hundred thousand we've been asking
you guys to support us we wanted to get
to a hundred thousand
before
which is coming up next week we hit it
it's it's a big deal you know since we
crossed a hundred thousand i've just
been screaming out let's go brandon all
week yeah i mean it's a pretty it is by
the way you know what a hundred means
though what's that three times a week we
made that so but do you realize like
imagine if you're at the hospital okay
husband and wife they just had a son the
entire time they know they want to name
their kid brandon as a four weeks ago
they were going to name the kid brandon
and then this whole thing goes to writer
and says let's go brandon right now wife
and husband are sitting there saying
brett isn't so bad babe we can name the
kid brandon babe we got to change we
can't name a brandon we can't name karen
we have to come up with a new name karen
i think has uh
i think karen's officially done yeah but
you know i think brandon's competing
though yeah i don't know not as much
karen
number one in the country on itunes
let's go brandon get out of here be
quiet beat adele be quiet i didn't know
that pull up this yeah
are you serious to see this there's no
way in the world pull that up insane i
listened to it yesterday i don't know
who sent it to me by the way somebody
sent it to me yesterday on instagram i
listened to it it's actually pretty
hilarious
uh uh let's go brandon uh wraps up i
already got it here i'm quicker than
david there's no way in the world you're
quicker than david buddy well now the
audience can't see kai
what's it say is is it really the number
one
fox business reaches top spot on itunes
chart get out of here
bryson gray raps look at australia
that's what's coming if we don't stand
up stop complying with them taking our
rights it's time to man up go lower
the the the rapper's name is who who's
the rapper by the way what's up
bryson gray and it's a couple other
people i think there's a couple people
that have done this song because i saw
some
wow the one you said
alexander
i've never heard a song any of these
karen getting viral but this brandon is
looks like it's here to stay at him i
don't i don't hold my beer so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]